j'ai quand même tenu à bien rappeler
parce que cet avenir sera mieux préparé
ce qu'il y à un terrain apaisé et pas de
violence s'il n'y a pas de manifestation
ni dans un camp ni dans l'autre qui
viendrait à compromettre des équilibres
vous le savez il ya beaucoup de
connaisseurs de la nouvelle calédonie au
sénat toujours extrêmement subtile alors
qu'allons nous faire j'ai envie de vous
répondre et représente ce que nous avons
dit que nous ferions je rappelle pour en
avoir rendu compte ici même notamment
que j'ai reçu l'essentiel en tout cas
ceux qui ont voulu venir des acteurs de
la vie politique calédonienne à paris
fin mai et nous avons élaboré un
processus qui s'est terminée le 1er juin
dernier qui nous a permis c'est ma
responsabilité de fixer la date du
troisième et dernier référendum donc la
priorité c'est bien entendu le dialogue
le dialogue nous avions décidé dès le
1er juin que quel que soit le résultat
du vote que par construction nous ne
connaissions pas à ce moment là
l'histoire ne s'arrêterait pas comme l'a
dit le président malgré nous avions
d'ailleurs
exposé toutes les conséquences et du oui
et du non pour l'ensemble des acteurs et
des électrices et des électeurs et nous
avions dit que de toute façon se
rouvrirait une phase de discussions non
seulement institutionnels mais le
président la république l'a rappelé lors
de son allocution dimanche sur tous les
sujets thématiques économiques et
sociaux il ya la situation des finances
publiques est extrêmement préoccupante
pour lesquelles mon gouvernement a déjà
pris ses responsabilités et je suis
sachez le en lien permanent avec le
président du gouvernement du territoire
en lien permanent sébastien lecornu
ministre d outre-mer est en ce moment
même encore il ya depuis quelques jours
sur place il est en train de discuter
avec l'ensemble des acteurs locaux dans
le calendrier
d'un contenu et d'une méthode de travail
là encore rien ne se fera
le dialogue tous les sujets sont sur la
table nous avons fixé des échéances que
vous avez rappelé monsieur le président
buffet nous verrons bien ce qu'il sera
possible de faire par rapport à l'une de
vos questions d'ici les élections
présidentielles rien ne se fera en
dehors d'un cadre apaisé nous sommes ici
pour veiller au respect les populations
et au respect des intérêts de la france
dans cette zone cher présent malhuret où
il ne nous a pas échappé que des
convoitises
défavorable à notre pays sont à l'oeuvre
[Musique]